I want to start with congratulations uh
I was surprised at the amount of action
and blood in the movie and I'm curious
what did Chris tell you going in about
the amount of blood he was looking
forward to putting on screen
um
gory uh um intention with with the movie
obviously the language of of the of how
much I didn't really know how much blood
was going to be involved I think until
until we were shooting and I was like
wow that was a lot of blood
um but I think uh I think it's uh yeah I
think that he that was he definitely
probably planned that all along uh to
have a lot of blood one of the things is
and I could be wrong about this but I
don't think you've ever been involved in
shooting action like this
um on this scale with so many action set
pieces what actually surprised you about
the process of doing action like this
um well I definitely have never been in
a in a kind of a horror movie
um and especially you know I I've been
in other action movies but the cool
thing about about Renfield is that uh
you know we had an amazing
um it's kind of like special effects
team uh we had a lot of practical
effects going off we like a lot of like
things were rigged and like like squibs
and stuff like that a lot of practical
like like um you know like fire and
things things like that that I never
worked with and you know our stunt team
was so great uh we would have within the
restaurant sequence there was like you
know that there was basically a runner
where the whole room was rigged and
you'd have to run the scene and if you
know you missed a line or or whatever
you know that you probably I pretty much
had like one chance to do it
um but it was but that was that part was
so cool about it I loved the shot where
Nick is in the apartment building where
he's jumping off and he's going down
he's basically breaking the body in half
and he's winking at you and you're
standing there I love that shot so yeah
what was it like actually filming that
sequence and you know because it's I
love that scene yeah that that sequence
was man that was that was a monster of a
sequence but the cool thing is is we
really did shoot at a kind of abandoned
uh Motel
um that that was his apartment building
so all of all of that was a like it was
on location none of it was done kind of
like on a stage or whatever so that was
all practical that was really cool
because
um there was so much like unnecessary
crazy things in in that like you know
body is getting broken and have arms
being torn off and and things like that
so it was a it was a crazy couple of
days but I mean it was so fun so fun
working with our stunt team I am a huge
fan of Nick Cage I would imagine you're
also a huge fan of Nick Cage how long
did it take when you when you saw him on
set before you started geeking out with
him over his previous roles oh man and
it kind of took a a while I think uh you
know I didn't want to I didn't want to
like come in hot with uh with the oh my
God you know kind of behavior but I
think after a couple of times I mean
he's such a he's such a nice guy and
he's so into the process and and um
really generous like I think with his
time and and himself so I think like it
was it was really a pleasure but yeah I
really enjoyed our kind of you know me
Nick and Nick kind of just hanging
hanging out in between scenes and stuff
was really cool yeah yeah I would have
peppered him from like the moment one
but you know that
that's oh I would have gotten thrown
offset anyway listen I gotta stop I'm
just gonna say congrats on the movie I
really do hope it's a huge hit thank you
for your time thank you for your time
thanks